so first of all do you ever not come
prepared like look prepared
on any given day for being like you look
like you're always prepared for camera
like i just threw this on down here
i'm wearing yoga pants down here
i am i'm wearing yoga plants with a
little flare um
i you know it's everyone watches these
nominee
nominations and so i was like let's give
the kids a look i haven't like
i've been um you know prepping and doing
i haven't been doing i haven't been
doing this so i was like let's give a
look you know for today
you know for the kids and inspire them
people need to see you know a little
glamour
and so that was like my goal to give a
little glamour well and
achieved yeah um also congratulations
not only a presenter but a nominee
can you talk about the way like
you know your very first nomination what
it felt how that changed your life
oh my gosh um well the beautiful thing
about
my first emmy nomination is that it was
history i am
i was the first openly transgender
performer to be nominated for an acting
in me um
and that was really really special the
history of it
meant a lot to me it meant a lot to my
community
and i don't know if any other trans
people have been nominated today like in
supporting categories i i was hoping i
wouldn't be the only one anymore i
haven't gotten
a chance to look at the other nominees
so it's it was that that it was special
because of that
and it was a dream you know it was i
love acting so much i love
telling stories so much and and that
just getting to do it
you know when i booked orange's new
black i i i was going to give up acting
and then you know two years later to be
nominated for an emmy was just after i
was gonna
quit um was kind of amazing and
um it's just i it's humbling because it
just makes me wanna work harder it makes
me wanna
continue to get better and to tell
stories
that touch people
i have to say it is very nice to finally
be able to see a set of nominees
and see a broad array of
diverse creators and diverse performers
being recognized you think it's fair to
say that the emmys are sort of leading
the way
um in terms of recognizing the
contributions of
performers actors creators of diverse
backgrounds
from the lgbtq plus community as well
i think the emmys have been leading the
way for a very long time i think
um over the years
there's i mean we have there's so much
progress that still needs to be made but
i think
the emmys and what is happening on
television has been way more diverse
than what we see on film
and i think i think that's been
reflected at the image for a long time
efficiently the nominations i
remember i think it was two years ago
um i remember the creative arts image
there was this unprecedented number of
emmy winners i remember the year that
samira won
and um i think nancy ford um was
nominated and there was just all of
these
um people of color who were nominated in
one image
that year i think it was a couple years
ago and so you know
and every year is different so i think
the emmys have always
um you know led the way in a lot of ways
in terms of diversity
do we do we need more folks more diverse
folks
absolutely um and
you know what i always always think
about what viola davis said when she
i think about so many things viola david
says but when she won her emmy for um
her first emmy for how to get away with
murder she said you can't win awards for
parts
it don't exist so it starts there starts
with casting
who are you super excited for in terms
of nominees i saw you get really excited
for zendaya
uh with just getting
because it's fun to say zendaya's name
or are you like super excited for that
nomination
i am such a huge fan of her
everything that she stands for and is
about and i love euphoria so much
and what zendaya does on that show
artistically the work the raw
performance that she gives is just
it's just it absolutely should be
recognized and i i love and adore
her but it's the work it is the work
that is so exciting and there's so many
wonderful actors who
who never get acknowledged and i just
shout out to all the actors who never
who do great work who never get
acknowledged and it's so so beautiful to
see such a beautiful raw performance be
acknowledged you know in a category with
heavyweights right there's that that
category is stacked with like
some you know formidable women and so i
and jeremy pope i was too excited to
hear his name as well for hollywood he's
such an
incredibly talented young actor who is
he was
who does the work and so i just i love
good acting
and i am just you know regina king is
just so brilliant
i think she really did and she has like
three or four emmys already
and i really think she did her best work
in uh watchmen
last year that show is at absolute
perfection
a perfection i don't think they need to
do another a second season it is like
i don't know if you can a show could get
any better and and kate blanche head
and i mean it's just i mean come on
there's just such a
beautiful work um that just inspires me
to just get better as an artist and to
work harder
perhaps like almost an embarrassment of
riches when it comes to content
yeah yeah well i gotta say thank you so
much for your time it was really fun
watching you do the uh presenting today
thank you all right have appreciated it
take care